a summer of protest
in libya after 10 years of war
with two rival governments battling for
control
basic services aren't being met
corruption is widespread
and the global pandemic has worsened the
situation
the majority in the room do not want the
status quo the un's top diplomat in
libya
stephanie williams has a message for the
country's
political class and they were put on
notice
you have an opportunity now to be
relevant you can rise to the occasion
or you know you can go the way of the
dinosaurs
a summit in tunisia has ended with 75
libyan delegates agreeing to hold
elections in december next year
but failing to decide on who will lead
the country
until then the un is focusing on what's
been achieved
what is happening now is basically
recycling all talk
more than giving real guarantees for
libyans that these sessions
will actually lead to a strong
government or one that's able to achieve
the real demands of the libyan people
the conflict has left people in this
oil-rich country
divided tired and poor negotiations will
continue in the coming weeks
aimed at bringing peace security and
stability
but there are few illusions that is
going to be easy
clear headache al jazeera tunis